- [Instructor] We are asked,
which of these complex numbers
has a modulus of 13?
And just as a bit of a hint,
when we're talking about the
modulus of a complex number,
we're really just talking
about its absolute value.
Or if we were to plot
it in the complex plane,
which is what we have right over here,
what is its distance from the origin?
So really you need to find
which of these complex numbers
has a distance of 13 from the
origin in the complex plane.
Pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
All right, now let's work
through this together.
Now one might jump out at you immediately
that's going to have a
distance of 13 from the origin.
If this is the origin right over here,
we see that if we go exactly 13 units down
we have this point right
over here, negative 13i.
So immediately right
out of the gate, I say,
"Okay, that complex number
has a modulus of 13,"
but is that the only one?
Well, we can actually visualize
all of the complex numbers
that have a modulus of
13 by drawing a circle
with the radius 13 centered at the origin.
So let's do that.
And we can see that it contains
the first complex number
that we looked for,
but it also seems to have included in it
this one right over
here, and we can verify
that the modulus right over
here is going to be 13.
We can just use the Pythagorean theorem.
So this distance right over here is 12.
And this distance right over here is 5.
And so we just need to figure out
the hypotenuse right over here.
And so we know that the hypotenuse
is going to be the
square root of 5 squared
plus 12 squared,
which is equal to the
square root of 25 plus 144,
which is equal to the square root of 169,
which indeed does equal 13.
So I like that choice as well.
And we can see visually that
none of these other points
that they already plotted
sit on that circle.
So they don't have a modulus of 13.
If we wanted to come up with
some other interesting points,
we could instead of having
negative 5 plus 12i,
we could have negative 5 minus 12i.
It would get us right over there.
And that would have a modulus of 13.
And notice, when you have
your complex conjugate,
it has the same modulus.
Or you could go the other way around.
Instead of negative 5 plus
12i, you could have 5 plus 12i.
That also would have a modulates of 13.
Or you could have 5 minus 12i.
That also would have a modulus of 13.
Now there's an infinite number of points,
any of these points on the circle,
that will have a modulus of 13.